on en parlait en début d'émission les
chenilles processionnaires sont déjà de
retour dans les Yvelines elles sont
censées arriver au début du printemps
vers le mois d'avril mais sont déjà bien
présentes dans certaines communes des
Yvelines pour en parler avec nous Alexis
Borges je le rappelle pour ce qui
n'était pas là avec nous au début de
cette émission vous êtes entomologiste à
l'office pour les insectes et leurs
environnements alors ces chenilles
processionnaires il en existe de
plusieurs espèces et elles sont
nuisibles est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer pourquoi alors le terme
nuisible est à prendre entre guillemets
effectivement parce que ça dépend
comment se positionne en fait finalement
en fait elles sont faut savoir qu'elles
sont présentes en fait en Europe de
façon très large depuis 100 ans après
Jésus-Christ donc ce qu'on a pas des
espèces invasives on a vraiment des
espèces autochtones de notre faune
française
certaines années il y a un peu plus de
chenilles donc d'observation
automatiquement les dérèglements qui
sont liés des fois notre mode de vie on
manipule un peu le végétal on va des
importer des des pins ce qui s'agit pour
celles qu'on observe en ce moment de
processionnaires du pain donc là ce
qu'on appelle l'en résinement va faire
qu'on va pouvoir attirer quelque part
l'établissement de ces chenilles hors de
ces milieux où elles ont leurs
prédateurs suffisant à une régulation
naturelle donc ces chenilles
effectivement faut en parler puisque ce
sont les deux seules espèces qui sont
vraiment j'irai dangereuses pour l'homme
et non pas du zip c'est-à-dire qu'au
niveau de la santé humaine il y a
vraiment un risque si on les manipule
alors les risques c'est que en fait ce
sont les seuls avoir une protéine qui va
entraîner via en fait la réception de
leur poils qui peuvent être donc
volatiles c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont déjà
lâchés par la chenille et après avec le
vent les déplacements d'air les poils
vont pouvoir toucher donc les mammifères
dont on fait partie et éventuellement
donc les animaux de compagnie qui
peuvent s'amuser à leur triche dedans
pour les pour les chiens les chevaux etc
donc suite à ça on va avoir vraiment une
suite de une cascade potentielle de
réaction ça veut aller des démangeaisons
des
œdèmes éventuellement des soinsments ça
peut aller jusqu'à des nécrose pour des
imaginer un chien qui va s'amuser à
mâchouiller plusieurs chenilles donc
c'est ce qu'il faut savoir c'est voilà
et rappeler ce sont les deux seuls
chenilles qui vont ces caractéristiques
de dangerosité sur les deux seuls avoir
cette protéine particulière qui entraîne
toutes ces réactions donc comment les
reconnaître alors là on a une facilité
avec cette chenille et puis ça sa
cousine qui est également présente dans
les Yvelines mais qu'on voit un peu
moins alors la première celle du pain
qu'on voit actuellement tout simplement
parce qu'il y a descend des pins pour
aller ce qu'on avait ce nymphoser se
transformer en papillon en chenille ça
donne un papillon donc à ce moment elles
ont besoin de se transformer dans la
terre donc à descente de leur art et
après donc elles vont s'enfuir et on on
voit bien parce que ce sont des
chenilles grégaires c'est à dire
qu'elles vivent à plusieurs ensemble
autour de leur plante haute leur plante
de nourrissage et quand elles descendent
et continuent à faire ça ensemble c'est
juste dans le sol qui est finalement
juste avant de rentrer dans le sol qui
vont se finalement se séparer mais font
quand même des chrysalides alors leur
stade immobile de transformation elles
le font quand même côte à côte donc
c'est vraiment le moment où il faut
vraiment prêter attention c'est en ce
moment puisque on a de l'avance comment
quand on marche en forêt faut faire
attention
on les voit de loin c'est c'est des
colonnes ça fait vraiment une colonne
militaire c'est les seuls également à
faire ça ça se distingue facilement on
n'aura pas une autre espèce qui qui
agira ainsi et en plus ce sont les seuls
liés au pain donc quand vous avez des
pins et vous voyez cette procession nous
leur nom voilà vous êtes à coup sûr de
de tomber sur cette espèce alors que
faire si jamais on a été piqué pendant
que ça va vraiment dépendre de de la
façon dont on a finalement eu
réceptionner ses poils donc je vous ai
dit des fois l'animal de compagnie ou le
petit enfant peut toucher la chenille
donc la première chose à savoir c'est
voilà que il y a un risque donc quand on
est parent c'est vraiment prévenir ne
nous donne pas toucher même si on a un
doute je n'ai poilu on est vite dit
toucher
après ça va être voilà si on a des
démangeaisons ça va être de se laver
abondamment à l'eau tout simplement si
on a les muqueuses qui sont touchées on
va utiliser par exemple des sérums
physiologiques après si ça va plus loin
faut pas hésiter à consulter un ophtalmo
un ophtalmologiste ou un médecin ça peut
entraîner éventuellement des problèmes
respiratoires tout ça ça va dépendre de
la quantité en fait de poils qu'on a
géré à savoir que les poils qui ont cet
effet sont des poils quasi
microscopiques ils font moins de de 0,2
mm donc des fois on voit des chenilles
avec plein de poils ça c'est un effet
protecteur touffu il plaît pas des
prédateurs eux c'est vraiment les micro
micro poils qui peuvent se détacher et
quand vous avez des coups de vent ça
peut amplifier le phénom qui imaginez
voilà ces chenilles dans une cour
d'école il y a vraiment un risque en
général voilà les communes les
agglomérations sont assez conscientes de
ce problème là donc elles savent prendre
les devants et enlever les nids qui
durent du début de l'automne jusqu'à
jusqu'à maintenant en fait tout ce nid
c'est ma prochaine question comment
est-ce qu'on fait pour limiter leur
prolifération bah en fait faut justement
agir quand elles sont regroupées plus
facilement accessibles c'est-à-dire en
fait couper alors on parle de nid en
fait une espèce de grande bourse soyeuse
des chenilles fabriquent de la soie
toutes les chenilles peuvent fabriquer
de la soie elles sont grégaires font une
espèce de grande bourse dans lequel
elles vont se loger donc des fois elles
vont se déplacer et refaire un nid dans
un dans l'arbre plus loin pour manger en
fait ou réguler la température mais
limiter l'action des prédateurs une
sorte de protection et de régulation de
température et d'humidité donc à ce
moment-là quand elles sont toutes à
l'intérieur un peu comme un nid par
exemple de guêpes et ben on va s'amuser
enfin c'est pas le mot on va les couper
le bout de branche dans ce sur le quai
des accrocher Sony et après soit
l'incinérée soit voilà le détruire
autrement mais voilà c'est la solution
la plus efficace si on s'y prend un peu
trop tard il y a des ce qu'on appelle
des collerettes qui peuvent être mis
autour des pins donc pas les autres
armes on les aura aucun intérêt
puisqu'elle ne mange uniquement que les
pins les professionnels du pain les
processions processionnaires du chêne
dont on verra un peu un peu plus tard
mais qui ne descend jamais au sol elles
sont uniquement liées aux chaînes c'est
plutôt en automne les professionnels du
chêne non alors les chenilles non ça va
être ça va être à la suite on va être à
la mi printemps on peut en voir jusqu'à
début juin et après voilà vont se
transformer en papillon mais elle elle
des fois elle marque moins puisqu'elle
descendent pas au sol donc elles vont
vraiment rester dans l'arbre donc la
collerette n'aura pas m'intéresse que
c'est quand les chenilles du pain
veulent descendre au sol qu'on va les
intercepter via une espèce d'entonnoir
qui ceinture l'arbre avec un gros sac
collecteur avec de la terre évidemment
il va faire leur chrysalide au lieu de
la faire dans le sol elles vont la faire
dans le sac qu'elles prennent pour le
sol et donc ça limite le contact de des
passants des promener en forêt par
exemple donc voilà c'est vraiment les
méthodes les plus efficaces et surtout
pas nuisibles à une biodiversité qui est
là pour réguler justement ces chenilles
à les concours les mésanges les huppes
les chauves-souris qui vont manger soit
les adultes de cette chemise soit les
chenilles donc il y a vraiment une bonne
régulation et ce dysfonctionnement fait
que des fois effectivement on peut avoir
plus de chenilles mais l'année d'après
on enverra moins ce que la régulation
est censée fonctionner et bien merci
beaucoup Alexis Borge d'avoir accepté
notre invitation